Hi, my name is Franklin Kalk, I'm 60 years old, I live in
Austin Texas. I took Warfarin for six months, about three years ago. I
had a blood clot, probably due to heavy travel, there were no other
complicating symptoms, or at least that was What we surmised at the time.
>> Now when you say you had a blood clot, that you know
to anyone who hasn't had a blood clot before that sounds kind of serious,
is that serious?
>> It is and it was kind of an interesting I mean I'll tell you the long
version, right? it started out I in retrospect probably for several
months I had some developing issues but didn't really know it at the time.
But looking back after after I discovered it, it became pretty clear that I
had these these symptoms.
>> And just so we know, what are those symptoms?
>> Well, I was having I was getting a little bit light headed occasionally. I
just thought it was from working out too
much or something like that, right? I travel
a lot, my ankles had started to swell on long trips on aircraft, which they
had never done before. And so, and I
just thought, well, it's inactivity. Well, of course,
it was, but it was also That I was having some of these other
things, you know, beginning to crop up in my, or, my, my, veins or arteries,
whatever. so, anyway, the story is, I was,
my wife and son were in Colorado on vacation. I was going to
meet them. I flew to Denver from Austin, I was walking
down the concourse in the Denver airport, talking to
my wife on the phone mo, going to my next
gate, because I was flying to Vale. And all
of a sudden, I felt like I was just walking
through molasses. It was amazing. I just felt like
I was in slow motion. And it wasn't even vertigo.
It was, it was you know, but I but
I kind of thought it was. Okay. Altitude you know.
Yada yada yada. RIght. So I said to my wife, I have to sit down. I
think i'm just you know, the thin air is getting to me in Denver. So I
went over to my gate kind of, stumbbled over I guess and I sat down and
put my head between my legs and that
didn't help and I just crashed on the floor.
So you know then I felt kind of woozy but
I was you know, people were worried about me. I got
up. I was able to get on the plane. And
then over the next couple of days, I felt fine. So,
no big deal. I was there for a week. I
then flew to Germany. And I got to Germany. I felt
fine. my first night there, I went to went into a
an establishment with a friend of mine to watch some soccer.
We had a couple of beers. Walking out I we hit the cobblestone streets and
I twisted my ankle a little bit. The next day, in that same leg, I had
a very tender spot on the back of my calf and I thought well, I must have
twisted more than just my ankle. No big deal. But it felt really tender and.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Tight, you know, like I had pulled a muscle.
>> Mm-hm. For a couple of days. And then, over time, it kind of went away.
So then, a few days later, I flew back to
Austin, got home. The next day, I had the same
pain, but it was in my groin. And, you know?
It was late at night. And I said to my wife,
you know? I, that's weird, it's moved. maybe I have
a blood clot. I'll go to the urgent care clinic
in the morning. So, the next morning. I got up
and it was big and it was really tender and red.
So I went in, and you know, the doctor
took one look and said, yeah, you have a blood
clot. Get, get across the street to the radiology group
and We'll do an ultrasound. So I went to cross
the street, had an ultrasound, it was pretty clear
during the ultrasound procedure. It was kind of neat because, you
know, they make you do things like flex your ankles
and on aircraft, you may have notice there are instructions
in aircraft magazines about moving your legs, you know, moving your knees
up and down or flexing your ankles. And they had a speaker
on the ultrasound device. So I could actually hear the blood flowing through my
veins as I flexed my ankles. So those exercises are
[LAUGH]
there for a reason I guess which I didn't know
at the time. so I thought, that's pretty cool. So
the radiologist said, it'll take me a while to look
at your chart. Go ahead and go home. I'll call you.
So I got five minutes away, literally, from the clinic
in my car and the nurse called and said, you
know, come back. So I turned around, came back and
they gave me a heparin shot immediately in my belly. And
>> And
what's heparin for?
>> Heparin is a very fast acting clot
basically, I'll call it clot breaker. I don't
know exactly the terminology, but it dissolves the
clot. And it's rapid, I mean it only
took a couple of days before the swelling
had virtually gone away. And I took that
for ten days. I had to take shots
in my belly, which was really really uncomfortable.
and then I started on Warfarin after that. So ten days on heparin and then I had
a sort of a ramp up into Warfarin, regime and took Warfarin for six months.
>> Now, I, I guess in your case in
particular it seems rather, even scary to some people
that some of those symptoms were even kind of.
Not benign but definitely synonymous with other kinds of causes.
>> Right, right.
>> and so
your realization, you know that it was a blood clot seemed r-,
rather important to getting it treated in time before something worse happened.
>> Right. Well I, you know I didn't really know anything about blood clots.
I, I have to say I wasn't educated about them at all. I, a
little better educated now of course but At the time, I really didn't know
anything. once the pain moved from my calf to my groin, I kind of,
you know, figured out. Oh, wait a minute. This
isn't just a muscle pull. And it's really tender. I
mean, you, I couldn't touch it without it being pretty
painful. So. You know, that was a little bit, you
know, muscle pulls don't really feel that way. With a
muscle pull, if you, you know, if you really massage,
may be okay. But I mean, just, you know, light
touch, I could feel it. So, it was something different.
>> Well, after you had the heparin treatment, and you
were able to sort of bust up the initial clot.
>> Right.
>> The Warfarin was prescribed to essentially prevent clots
from forming For a period of time in the future.
>> Right.
>> Now, is this a pill that you had to
take every day? Well, first of all, is it a pill?
>> It's a pill.
>> And is it something you had to take every day?
>> Right. It's a pill, you take it every day, and, I'm
trying to, I can't remember exactly whether I actually took more than
one in a day to ramp up to some
level or not. I don't remember, but It took about
two weeks to determine that I was stable on
it. That my my clotting factors were at a normal
level and not varying a lot. because that's one
of the things they look for. so I had to
get, you know, blood tests every every well twice
a week for two weeks and then every week after.
But it's a pill and, long term over six months I took it once a day.
>> And so obviously I guess the concern
is since the Warfarin itself modulates the clotting factors.
>> Right.
>> And how effective and efficient they work for
you, that too much Warfarin could be a bad thing.
>> Absolutely.
>> So when your doctor prescribed this for
you what were the considerations that went into I
mean did he have lots of special instructions for you? Did he try to get a lot
of information from you? Did you have to
modify anything in your life, to accommodate the dosing?
>> yes, all of the above, he gave gave me some fairly, they weren't super
detailed, but fairly detailed instructions. I, you
know, once I'd discovered and had verified at
the doctor that I had a clot and that I was, you know, because these
shots will remind you if nothing else.
because compared to the shots the Warfarin itself
was not really a big deal for me in terms of the you know, the ingestion.
>> Sure.
>> The shots hurt. they hurt for quite a while after taking, maybe 20 minutes
I would have to lie down and just try to relax because I had such
a massive pain right in my belly where the, where I got the shot. anyway
the, the Warfarin was so, so there
were relatively detailed instructions. I had educated myself
after finding about the clot. And so, the doctor,
you know, more or less cursorily went over the
instructions with me, rather than go through them word
by word, because he knew I had read them, and
had begun to educate myself. And, I was lucky
because my personal physician was also my next-door neighbor.
So he knew my lifestyle and knew that I
was going to be, you know, pretty diligent about understanding this,
you know,
>> Mm hmm.
>> This condition.
>> Well, what were some of the special exceptions? we know that vitamin K is
>> Right.
>> Really important rather the amounts of vitamin
K, because vitamin K's an essential component for clotting
>> Right
>> So did you have to alter your diet,
or did you have to pay special attention to it?
>> Yes. So, before, and this is another interesting sort
of predetermining factor, I think. Not just the travel but
I ate a lot of leafy green vegetables, which have, those
are really the main sources in our normal diet of vitamin K.
for example iceberg lettuce doesn't have much but
romaine does. Right? Kale has an enormous amount. Spinach.
I love spinach. I, I ate a lotta spinach before that. So I had to cut back.
And I really, I didn't eliminate them from my diet but I cut way back. And I
did. Control very carefully the intake, so I I
knew exactly how much I was taking each day.
There were some things I totally eliminated from
my diet, for example, avocados. And the reason for
that is avocados, you can have two avocados that
look the same, but yet one will have very
little vitamin K, and the other can have an
enormous amount. Per unit weight. So the, the variability
was just, is something that you know you would
you just imagine well I'm not going to eat those
then, right? Because I don't want to inject that kind of variability into my
diet. I, I'm a big fan of if I can control, control things
through my diet I'll be better off. So, I kind of laugh once
in a while and say, I went to meat and potatoes for six months.
[LAUGH]
>> The opposite direction of what some people end up having to do.
>> Right. And the other thing that was
a little bit interesting to me, and I don't
remember how important a factor this was made out
to be, but I know I wasn't suppose to
get really over heated when I worked out.
So don't really stress your body out and you
know, because now you're making your liver work pretty
hard. And that's where the clotting factors come from
in your blood stream, right? So you need to be
really careful about, about how you control your you know the
energy expenditure that your body goes through. So, and I,
and I had a, a, my clot occurred in early July.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So in Austin, July is the hottest time of year. So, you
know, rather than. I'm not going to go outside and run at noon. Right?
[LAUGH].
>> Right.
>> Because I'm not just going to get, super heated. So, that was a, that was
a, a pretty substantial change. Another change, was it, because you have
to worry about your blood, you know, maybe, maybe not being, so, maybe not being
able to clot so much anymore.
>> Right, I mean, Warfarin has the effect
of thinning blood, so that it doesn't clot as
easily, but then the concern obviously is that
you don't clot enough when you need to clot.
>> Right Yeah. So another thing I did, was I, I had taken
baby aspirin one a day at that point. And that's a different way to
thin the blood, right. As you get older, they kind of recommend that
for your heart. But that's really a, I think that's a platelet lubricity issue.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Whereas Warfarin is really about clotting
factors in the bloodstream, which is a
completely, it's a chemistry thing, right. And
so, I had stopped taking aspirin during
that time. Just because it was another variable we wanted to eliminate. And so
I really changed my diet pretty dramatically.
I went out and bought the Coumadin Cookbook.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> Which was really great for meat and potato recipes.
>>
[LAUGH].
Well, that sounds like just the, diet and
the recipe for some people out there already.
>> Right, exactly.
>> Yeah.
>> Now where there any like besides your diet
any special activities that you know you were precluded from
doing? Besides even, you know, like you said exercising in
the heat. was there any major concern about getting injuries?
>> Right.
>> Or, or or stopping bleeding if it were to occur?
>> Yes, In fact,
when I had the weekly blood test one thing
I noticed right away was that the bleeding did
not stop. Just a little pin prick in the
finger is what was needed to get the blood test
taken. So, you know, you can usually just do
this with your fingers for two, three minutes, and then
the blood will stop, right? But it would take
30 minutes or more. Because, you know, we were trying
to keep my blood relatively thin. the other thing, the
other lifestyle change for me was I like to drive cars
fast at the race track. And, I couldn't do that
anymore because of the concern about blunt-force trauma. Any kind of
accident, you know, if you have a bad bruise you
could you know potentially bleed to death if you're blood doesn't
clot well. So, you know, that's, that's the kind of
thing that you know, really was a big change for me.
>> Now, I'm
interested too sort of in the more personal side. I mean, this is all
very technical and obviously things about your
life had to change. You know, from
the event of having a clot itself, and then of course having to go
through, like you said, the ten day
heparin treatment, and the six months of warfarin.
>> Right.
>> Did it have, you know, does this have a
psychological impact or an emotional impact on you and your family?
>> Yes. Oh yeah. for me personally, I stopped traveling
for about six to eight weeks. And then
after that, I remember still the first aircraft
that I got on. I was fidgeting. And it was Austin to Dallas, you know, literally
a 35 minute flight. And then I went
Dallas to Milwaukee. So maybe an hour, right,
not very far. I was fidgeting the whole
time just trying to keep my blood flowing.
[LAUGH]
I mean it was really, it really changes your attitude. I
mean for me it was my first glimpse of mortality idea right.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I mean that was, that was a big deal and I think also
you know just having to go through a dietary change for the first time in
my life. And strictly control my diet.
You know, my attitude had always been, I'll
eat as much as I want, anything I want, I'll just exercise to keep my weight,
you know, where I want it. It wasn't like that
anymore. So that was a big change, and you know, it
was a big change for my family because now all
of a sudden If we were, if they were going to have
kale or spinach, I wasn't. So it was almost like
we had to cook for two different diets. Right so, I
mean, and just things like that. I mean that was
that was part of it. But I think also there was
probably some worry, you know, from the other family members about,
you know, is dad okay, or is my husband okay or.
>> Right well, you know, there are, there's a lot of new
information out there about genetic variability,
and certain genes that affect your
metabolism of Warfarin. We're just curious, do you know if you, do
you know of anything about your genetics with regards to that sensitivity
[INAUDIBLE]
Warfarin yet.
>> I do not know. And I didn't know there was
a genetic component, so that's good. I'm going to go study it actually.
>> Yeah. we'll just ask as a follow up then. So this is
something that you'd be interested in knowing about yourself then in case you.
>> Absolutely.
>> Ever needed Warfarin in the future?
>> Absolutely. Right. Yeah, and you know there's
has been there's has been stroke, or heart disease
in my ancestry.
>> Mm-hm.
>> you know recent ancestry. both sides of my
family father and mother. I've always looked at that and
said. Well, you know? Back then, people smoked a lot.
And they didn't have very good diets. And I'm in
much better health than my father was at my age,
and his father. But, you know? It kind of makes me
wonder. And I know there has been a history of
strokes on my mother's side of the family, in particular.
And of course, that's one, you know, one by-product of blood clots.
>> Oh, absolutely.
[CROSSTALK]
>> so overall, you're pretty pleased then that
a drug like Warfarin does exist at all?
Obviously to assist. but you know, this was
a big sort of life changing event for you.
>> Right. Right.
>> If you could you know, talk to someone that was either just diagnosed with
a blood clot and was going to have to go on Warfarin over a period of time, or
if you were going to have to give advice to a family member
or friend of someone who was going to have to undergo that. Do you
have any helpful or important advice or opinion that you'd like to share
with them. Something that you think it's important and they should know about?
>> Well when I read about Warfarin I thought,
you know a couple of things. It's, it's almost like
Aspirin. It was discovered quite a while ago. Almost,
well early in the last century. Maybe 1930s, or 20s.
it's amazing that such an effective drug has
not really had yet a replacement that works kind
of for everybody, you know what I mean? that
was interesting to me. because it has been used
really, for other purposes than treating blood clots, before
that At first I thought I'm not sure I
want to put this in my body, but it really
wasn't all that bad. The actual ingestion of the,
of the drug itself. I really felt nothing
and you know I felt perfectly normal. so
that was good. And I think. They're, you
know, don't fear, right? On the other hand, for
me, I, I stabilized rapidly. And, and, you
know, my my clotting factors in my blood
stayed very constant over time. Maybe that was
just discipline. So, my advice would be, follow a,
a diet, you know. Be really strict about your diet.
That doesn't mean, you know, deprive yourself. But, but be
consistent with it. So that your, your, your body is
being presented with the same Chemistry from nutrition. I mean,
I think that's really important. the other thing is that,
you know, taking the drug, again, is not the end
of the world. And, if you're a typical person that
gets a blood clot, you don't take it forever. I mean,
in my case, you know, it was six months and I was off it and that
was, you know, that was four years ago so you know, I think, but it, it,
it does change your lifestyle a little bit or maybe a lot. I guess depending on
the you know the gravity of the situation. But it isn't the end of the world
[LAUGH].
>> Well we're glad that you had more friend
[LAUGH]
and that it worked successfully for you, and
that you're here to share your story with us.
>> Oh thank you very much.